hey guys so we just got to Vegas and I'm
so excited because today we are going to
the imagine dragons grammy live stream
show so to explain this to you
target is sponsoring the Grammys but
instead of running an actual target
commercial they are doing a live stream
performance here from beg and so pumped
up because I get to go and interview the
band and the target gave us some target
goodies and if you guys have watched any
of my videos you know I'm obsessed with
target so this is kind of like this is
like a dream trip come true shot
Mogi stickers you'll know right away no
you're gonna wait yeah I think you are
wait I don't know go to lunch
a lot of miners here and kind of
fangirling a little bit hi Jenna
I think everyone's more pumped up about
this pizza right now I was waiting I was
waiting economy and that's where imagine
I saw your shadow running up I'm like oh
gosh roll out Logan it feels like we're
going to prom selfie stick turn up
feels weird
you're taking like the best selfies of
this stick hey guys what's up so I'm
hanging out with magic dragons and we're
in Las Vegas right now and you guys are
going to be performing pretty much like
in the middle of the street yeah exactly
like in the middle of the street in an
intersection yeah so tonight what are
you guys performing it's gonna be aired
on the Grammys it's just kind of crazies
anything like it's been done before I
mean it's kind of impressive you're
right nothing's groundbreaking we're
gonna be playing shots which is the
first song on the record
hey you already did well got my face
blemishes stop the filter automatic
we're outside the forum is about to
start our day to a close but I've had so
much fun we got to hang out with so many
amazing people we got to see Magic
Dragons I got to interview them and
depending upon how I edit this video you
guys can go check out the full interview
there'll be a link in the description
and an annotation somewhere here they
don't make jenamae I should okay Janice
the energies for Queen this is why you
haven't seen in the annotations in on
life yeah Jenna's one job annotating hey
it's okay it's all right half the time
they don't work anyway and they don't
work on go boom guys I love you it's
time for bed this wall will hurts my
eyes I'll see you in the next video so
works had to play that tonight kind of
get our hands dirty with the new record
this would be our first real experience
with that self really